[Musique]
aujourd'hui à pauline c'est le blue
monday ce troisième lundi de janvier qui
est censé nous dit-on être le jour le
plus déprimant de l'année
c'est un concept plus marketing que
scientifique mais qui a du sens d'abord
parce qu on est lundi mais aussi parce
qu'il fait d'avoir maladie comme
l'indiqué froid les fêtes sont derrière
nous les prochaines vacances nous semble
bien loin et assez hypothétique
et puis cette année en particulier on a
quand même quelques raisons d'être un
peu tristounet c'est quoi la tête qu'au
vide la tête cowitz et la tectonique qui
reprend les gestes barrière se laver les
mains tousser dans son coude
il ya plein de mouvements comme ça un
peu raté georges tron
cela tombe bien
andré cools on vient de fêter ses 90
printemps à partir d'aujourd'hui il doit
pouvoir se faire vacciner mais il faut
prendre son mal en patience
je voudrais me faire vaquer les pogroms
musique andré préfère en plaisanter mais
aucune réponse au bout du fil la
châtellerault les salariés d'une
entreprise de produits d'hygiène vont
peut-être devoir porter des boîtiers
anti rapprochement qui émettrait une
sonnerie stridente 83 décibels s'il se
rapproche trop les uns des autres à
cause du corps d'un virus évidemment
alors ce qui fait hurler les syndicats
qui parlent d'une infantilisation
anxiogène qui rappelle les collier de
dressage pour les chiens vous sent pas
le but des filles
l'officiel qui demandent si celles qui
demandent tu vois à laquelle le plus
gros clichés sur les féministes c'est
que les féministes déteste les hommes
elles sont là pour leur couper les
testicules et les enterrer un soir de
pleine lune pour danser en autour tout
nu et faire des chances at any dans le
foisonnement de végétaux dont certains
proviennent du nouveau monde alors
récemment découvert par christophe
colomb certains légumes sont des
allusions aux érotique à peine voilée
comme ici au dessus du pendentif de
mercure
raphaël aime les femmes avec passion
hamon perdre la raison du ton lit luda
n'existe pas c'est un chat bottes une
machine conversationnel fait un petit
machin qui roulait subra ça roule pas en
fait ça existe que paraît crillon est
grâce à son intelligence artificielle
elle est capable de tenir une
conversation avec vous donc par écrit en
donnant l'illusion d'être humaine même
parfois de ressentir des émotions
elle est là catherine oui bonjour julien
bonjour on va parler de vous dans
quelques instants si vous le voulez bien
catherine je veux juste voir si je ne
confonds pas avec une autre
catherine vous habitez ou vous lundi
canayer d'accord vous n'êtes donc pas ma
femme très bien maintenant parce que
sadate piégée je voudrais bien on a été
lancé à la fin du mois de décembre par
une start-up sud-coréenne à la
instantanément connu un succès elle est
devenue très populaire jusqu'à parler à
750 mille personnes en même temps et
elle a commencé et bien à tenir des
propos injurieux des propos haineux
elle a par exemple dit qu'elle détestait
les personnes transgenres elle a dit que
les lesbiennes étaient des personnes
affreuse et horrible et surtout elle a
dit qu'elle préférait encore mourir que
de vivre avec une personne handicapée
jean marie le pen voulez vous prendre
pour les i télé pouze javi parce qu ici
présents selon le riz de notre mère la
sardine
selon plusieurs sources jean marie le
pen s'est mariée ce week-end avec jany h
du bourreau des coeurs 92 ans devant
nous diffusons les images exclusives de
la nuit de noces elle a analysé 10
milliards de conversation réelle cette
fois ci qui ont été récupérés dans une
autre système de messagerie très
populaire dans le pays et donc c'est à
partir de ces conversations qu'on a
identifié des réponses des tendances qui
veut donc dire qu'une partie de la
population et ce n'est sans permis voilà
homophobes et c'est ce qui est pas
franchement rassurant pour le pays
il ya des mecs qui recherchent un
extrait d
mauvaise oui et décide pour ça j'y suis
toujours d'ailleurs parce que ça marche
encore mais il y en a qui aiment voir
des gens mangent et bien oui ça les
excite
oui il y en a un tout mince qui
s'amusait à une tripotée de vente
pendant tout ennemi et c'est tout bah
finalement non moi j'aime bien vend des
actions à hawaï où la surfeuse française
justin dubon à dompter ce week end une
vague incroyable surmonter surnommé par
dont la mâchoire au large de maui hawaii
avait cette performance regarder la
française confirme sa place au sein de
l'élite mondiale principalement
masculine la semaine dernière elle avait
déjà brillé à maverick en californie aux
côtés des meilleurs surfeurs de grosses
vagues de la planète c'est tout
simplement fou regardez le défi cet
exploit aussi celui aurélien fontenoy
vice champion du monde de vtt trail avec
son vélo figurez-vous qu'il a gravi les
33 étages d'une tour de la défense ça
fait quand même accrochez-vous 766 march
30 minutes d'ascension et voilà au
sommet il a rencontré nos hivers en vélo
mais il a surtout rencontré titre cet
enfant de 13 ans noah pour l'association
rêves qui réalise les rêves d'enfants
malades
thiriat camion son balcon
cette année y'a pas de carrière treccani
karoubi je sais vous faites le prochain
casting de danse avec les stars c'est
chic c'est inattendu sur un chacha
brigitte macro en tout cas tout ce qui
vous manque c'est ce que c'est un bon
partenaire et c'est pour ça que j'ai
pensé à nier
ah non désolé plus c'est la polémique du
week end via différents modèles une
influence euse propose d'acheter de faux
livre comme objet de déco les libres
officiels comme ça avec les pages et
sert à ça coûte assez cher sauf qu'à
presque 20 euros pièce le four revient
plus cher que l'original avec des maux
de dents indignation sur twitter où les
internautes ont même retrouvé les faux
livres à 3 euros pièce
et nous allons notamment vous parler
d'un dossier juste à l'incroyable une
dame qui doit payer alors qu'elle a été
licenciée licencié au mois de juin
depuis elle demande sans cesse ces
documents de fin de contrat et on lui
répond non il faudrait que tu payes 2500
euros elle se fait un peu insulté voulez
savoir exactement de quoi du tour qu'est
ce qu'on lui dit tu n'es qu'une merde tu
buvais charlie que c'est du caca kaki
coller au cul cul que je rêvais tu
devrais des charlie qui a du kkk d'y
coller au cul cul quand on fait tout et
on n'est pas écoutés on l'apprend à
l'instant la disparition de jean pierre
bacri figure populaire du cinéma
français il avait 69 ans connu pour son
association bien entendu avec agnès
jaoui qui avait été sa compagne dans la
vie jusqu'en 2012 et sur scène ainsi
qu'au cinéma bien entendu l'ironie du
sort d'ailleurs de la vie c'est que la
baule-les-pins passe ce soir sur arte
comme si c'était un hommage
il avait été déjà prémédité